hey youtubers its charlie
welcome to part three of my Game of
Thrones Season 4 preview video this
video will cover Danny and the
characters in the east as well as a few
supporting characters that didn't make
it into my other videos there's also
been a few updates to the series that
I'll go over to and because enough
people requested it I'll include an
extra long warning for spoilers but
enough of that onto dragons so season 4
is gonna pick up for Danny right where
it left off in season 3 if you remember
she's now the mother of all these people
in young Kai that she freed and since
the dragons were born she's kind of been
like this profit figure to all these
people
but now she's going to become more of a
leader so before I talk a lot about
Danny in season 4 you have to understand
what the producers are doing with season
4 as it applies to books 3 & 4 remember
it's supposed to cover the last half of
book 3 but they'll also include some
stories from season 4 that's just
because the books are so long basically
it just means the stories are all gonna
get a lot simpler so a lot of stuff is
gonna get left out but we can talk more
about those things once they start
releasing episode synopsises so the big
problem for Danny in season 4 is the way
she thinks of herself if you remember in
the beginning of the season she's more
of a conqueror she takes on a stupor he
gets an army and then she burns
everything else to the ground and by the
time she gets to young Kai she's
actually a savior she's trying to free
all these people so that's only gonna
get more pronounced as season 4 gets on
that idea is only strengthened by the
fact that that last shot in season 3
with all those people lifting her up
those aren't warriors those are just
regular people I'll talk more about
where those people are going when we get
to spoilers but right now let's talk
about some of the supporting characters
that I think are really important
they're really for supporting characters
that I think are really important to
Danny's story sir Jorah Barristan Selmy
missandei and Daario now the showrunners
have always given a lot of extra scenes
to supporting characters that they
didn't necessarily have in the books
like Shaye so I think that's only gonna
happen more in season four one of the
really cool things I think about Game of
Thrones is is that it defies a lot of
traditional fantasy conventions and that
not every character has a polar opposite
or an evil twin unless you consider
Stannis's smoke baby to be his evil twin
all the characters really have their own
set of motivations
for all the evil or stupid or brave
things they do and a lot of times their
characters like Jamie for instance will
dramatically change during the course of
a book that just goes into the no one is
safe theory so now it's time to get into
spoilers so here we go spoilers so Dani
and her Nomad City will travel to marine
and she'll do the exact same thing she
did in young Kai she'll basically
liberate all these people and marine but
she'll find out that she's got so many
people depending on her that she has
more responsibilities to them than she
does to her own quest for the Iron
Throne
so her conflict in deciding what the
future of her army will be is a big part
of that fourth book and will be a season
four of course if you haven't read the
books when Danny gets to marine her
story actually picks up again and
Dancing with Dragons she's not really in
the fourth book so they're gonna
probably overlap some of those stories
into season three that just goes back to
the idea of condensing a lot of stories
from across separate books let's talk
about big episodes so obviously there's
always at least one or two episodes of
season where the biggest events happen
and you just say oh my gosh this is
gonna be amazing
so right now george RR martin over the
past couple seasons has always written
that ninth episodes that's like red
wedding Battle of Blackwater Bay
Ned getting his head chopped off but in
the next season he's actually writing
the second episode so I think it's a
fair bet to say that we're gonna see at
least two big things and reality they're
about four big events that I'd like to
talk about one is the purple wedding
I am definitely sure that that is going
to happen in the second episode just
because there's so many events after it
in book three just chronologically
that's when it has to happen to is Danny
taking marine that actually might not
come until the end of the season but I
think it's a good fair bet that she's
going to march on marine at least by the
middle of the season
then there's the wildling attack on the
Nights Watch I think that would probably
come later in the season though and then
four is meeting cold hands and going to
the green seer that's more dance with
dragons it's a fair bet that that's
going to happen earlier in the season
just based on when we last saw a brand
there's one more thing that definitely
might happen but it's still only a rumor
and I think it will happen later in the
season and that is Lady Stoneheart I'll
talk more about that in just a second so
a few of you asked me to talk about
characters the
didn't necessarily make it into my other
videos including brand Lady Stoneheart
Brienne and Samwell so the last time we
left bran and OSHA and their group they
were actually on their way to go beyond
the wall that's actually where they meet
cold hands I don't know if they're gonna
be featured in the first episode of the
season but I do think that they'll meet
cold hands in that second episode I
don't know how big the cold hands
character is going to be in this season
just because those characters aren't
necessarily main characters on the show
they don't get nearly as many scenes to
say like Peter Dinklage or Kit Harington
one of the really cool things though for
bran is that he learns a lot more about
his powers from this person called the
green seer much later in the series cold
hands actually takes them there and I
have a lot of theories about who cold
hands is - spoiler alert sorry I'm just
joking about that it's actually I think
Benjen Stark it's never confirmed so
there's still just a rumor that's just
my own theory but he's basically like a
white like an undead person who helps
them out so it's a little bit strange
and it's never fully explained by george
RR martin at least in this book I think
maybe in winds of winter we'll find out
about them a little bit more you can
think of that greenseer helping brand
out as being like obi-wan Kenobi if he
lives on hah because remember they are
beyond the wall so it is really cold
Samwell actually ends up learning a lot
more about the White Walkers just by
reading a lot of the books that no one's
bothered to read of the Nights Watch he
does help Jon Snow regain a lot of
control over the Nights Watch
during the wildling attack I don't think
that will happen till later in the
season and there's also a subplot with
Keeley's baby that I don't know that
we'll see in this next season it might
be season 5 before we see that Brienne
actually has a lot to do in this new
season you remember the last time we saw
her in King's Landing she had just split
from Jamie Jamie will actually put her
on another quest he'll give her this
really special sword that was melted
down from Ned Stark's sword it's called
Oathkeeper and she'll be charged with
finding another start Sansa but she
actually ends up fleeing to the Vale you
remember that place where Tyrion almost
died in the first season
so that quest will basically start at
least somewhere halfway between Episode
five and seven Lady Stoneheart the
person who is on everyone's minds a lot
of people think that she won't be on the
show next year just because Michelle
Fairley the actress is on season three
of suits but she's actually just a guest
actress and in a lot of interviews very
recently she's been very guarded about
the way she talks about her character
she keeps a very present tense so I'm
inclined to believe that she's still
going to be in season 4 but only for
maybe one one and a half episodes
including that ninth episode and
probably definitely the finality let me
know what you think write in the
comments if you think they're gonna
include Lady Stoneheart in season four
and what stories from the third and
fourth books do you think they're gonna
cut out what's going to make it into
season four and what's going to get
turned into something different there's
so much to talk about on Game of Thrones
my next video is actually going to cover
just the magical aspects of the show
that's right I'm gonna do an episode
next Monday subscribe to get it it'll
deal with magic of the three I crow the
magic of the red God and the magic of
the White Walkers so there's a lot of
different religions a lot of different
magics on the game of Thrones so I'm
just gonna do a magic video and it's
gonna be magical in the meantime you can
click here to get my Man of Steel video
I talk about the sequel and the trilogy
as well as give my review of the movie
seriously watch it it was a lot of fun
and you can click here to watch the rest
of my Game of Thrones Season 4 previews
high fives
you